welcome to this video right ten of the
candidates tournament it's a long
tournament isn't it 10 um and we are
still got including in this 10th round
five to go yeah I'm not this leading
quite clearly but still people behind
that can stow yeah there is some some
tension left let's see let's see this
game Kramnik Svidler chronixx on fifty
percent but he has lost horribly
yesterday against um no not yesterday
they've been there was a rest day but
lost in the the round before the two
high aachen silly eyes on minus one not
in in great shape he had a big oven down
tournament let's see what happens here
kramnik playing d4 no surprise and
swidler playing f5 yeah not a real
surprise he had played it before I
against Mammadyarov getting away from
his groom fault yeah it wasn't just a
one game kind of idea he had prepared it
obviously in a more detailed fashion now
getting giving it a go against Kramnik
yeah he also has a history of losing in
the gruene fought against Kramnik so um
yeah for instance in a very crucial game
in last year's candidates tournament he
lost one of those green fault endings
against Kramnik and this was really
hurting him very much in this tournament
situation I was actually a present at
that game watching life in London and
back then also thought why isn't he
doing something else ok and simply
because he has lost so often with this
opening ok so we know that the Dutch two
minutes for one move ok let's see you 93
already a minor surprise because it
commits wide a bit early but now Cromley
comes up with something something
extraordinary he plays III III move I
never really am yeah
have taken serious before in this
position normally white is just simply
fear chattering mostly even starting
with that I moved to and yeah it is
generally believed that in the in Dutch
setups on the bishop is very well placed
on g2 as it controls let's say in though
in the Leningrad Dutch it supports the
d5 spot to to just give you an example
what I'm talking about it's just just
something like that you see that white
has this outpost or this this advanced
pawn on d5 that is supported by at the
bishop on g2 and this type of position
is very common and therefore it's very
unusual to see III plate he simply wants
to get out of preparation I guess and
get in some owner new ideas surprisingly
in hospital as not playing g6 is playing
b6 I would have expected that you would
play g6 simply in the spirit of the
Leningrad SEF plate before um certainly
a v6 is also a fine move um here I also
would have been interested yeah it would
be interesting to see what Kramnik idea
here is mean the even the stolen ball
which is some sometimes I'd with a bit
of suspicion by us by players in the
stone wall against year 3 and let's say
something like that is considered to be
a perfectly okay for black um yeah we
didn't see that so we can play b6 yeah
and now if white just plays routinely
like Bishop b3 for example e6 yeah
something like that we would get sort of
a Dutch Queens Indian hybrid yes what if
white goes now well probably black plays
who should be 70 of it let's say
something something like that could have
happened um yeah it did
in this game because chronic now played
the interesting move d5 deflated very
quickly so it may be yet even looked at
this move b6 which really seems obscure
to me and CEA's Villa had used like 20
minutes on b6 interesting I really don't
do know why what the point is to play be
six instead of e-cigs yeah okay calm
neck plate d5 and that's a fourth an
interesting move it leads to entirely
unconventional positions after Bishop d7
and Bishop c4 this is simply a very
strong pawn that at the moment makes it
very difficult for like to develop like
must play something like now something
like it so phrasing it wrong we must
play c6 in this position this is what
what's villa did um it's very difficult
otherwise to get your pieces out as you
cannot go e6 obviously instead of which
should be 76 here it's probably
questionable because here check the
endgame could be a slightly more
comfortable for white the e6 porn is a
bit weak it'sit's nothing terribly
serious but maybe a nothing that's what
I wanted to go into and this is frankly
the more interesting way to play yeah
now why played 93 you need to protect
you d 5 taking us does not make much
sense really just the developing black
so C 693 yeah and here black is
basically out of moves besides taking on
d5 so we took down and I think this is
also just fine Knight takes and now esox
all this is very very logical black
cannot really do something else we
taking this is slightly questionable
knight c6 yeah maybe you can even do
that but it looks somewhat we had a six
is just speeding
blacks development in a way getting the
Queen to f6 yeah now castles was played
and Bishop c5 yeah Bishop c5 this move
was heavily criticized by swindler in
the press conference which has some some
parts of um he didn't like it because of
chrome Nick's reply which was Bishop d2
yeah the the point is that now it is
really really risky for black to take on
be too you can try that I mean the
computer is not not giving it as
completely terrible or something and
yeah but it's not a move that you want
to play for example 94 can be a real a
real problem your queen is this cut not
be five as possible and this gives right
enormous compensation the truth about
all this of course is that Bishop c5 is
not precise he pointed out that knight
c6 is the better move which is certainly
true the main differences if white now
tries bishop d2 intending to get this
piece to see through the temple here
black can really take it's a huge
difference because now with the bishop
back on f8 black actually has this
additional return route yeah and also a
default of course is not protected by a
night so Knight d4 its entirety
pointless i just take twice and a rook
be one yeah black hand can even go back
to to f6 c3 is amiss but then there is a
difference with the bishop back on evade
i can actually play here and go to see
five maybe yeah Swilley are certainly
right 96 is some more precise move but
this gives away some ground but it is of
course not fatal
we just see that white gets to this set
up with Bishop 1c3 with the temple a 3
out before yeah you could actually argue
that before it's not really a threat and
a 5 not necessary but still have
prevented that which I understand very
well I mean you don't really want to
give your opponent this kind of space
gaining a push moves like before yeah
maybe maybe it was not necessarily d5
was was was an alternative you can just
put the bishop on d6 if be here before
comes but ok I don't think that you can
criticize that in any way Queenie two
castles rook 81 Java that's all very
normal looking yeah in this position now
spitler played the move d5 here you
could actually argue that maybe it was
was more precise 22 to delay this move
for a moment it's difficult to play
without it in the long run as white will
get some pressure on d 7 the question is
does not just black I really need to
play this d5 advance immediately he has
many moves to somewhat improve the
position and maybe wait until why it has
committed to do something and that is
not really fitting well with d5 for
example just to show like like it
something like that rook to e8 and right
now just just for instance tries to pile
up only then play D Phi which makes the
rooks look bit silly this is just a
sample line to illustrate what I mean it
can be sometimes an idea to just delay
the move that you sort of need to play
at one point to delay it and wait until
there is a better moment to get it in um
what Black is in the long run also a bit
afraid of is probably the movie for
opening up the position
in the center and this is also a reason
why d 5 is a move that you probably want
to get in at some some point okay played
immediately yeah Kramnik it went to be
five not not much else and tonight it
seven yeah immediately chatting ring the
bishop and yeah how to assess this
position in general um if you if you
look at this I think it's a big
difference if you look at this position
from a human eye with the human I'm or
if you are just look at and computer
evaluation this is a pretty typical type
of position where the humans view use
the situation a bit differently than a
computer the computer is just giving all
this and the family upcoming moves as
completely equal um maybe that's true
maybe that's true with the computers are
so strong nowadays that they are right
obviously in almost all cases but one
thing that black always needs to be
aware of and why the position is in a
practical game in a way somewhat tricky
for black is that he has played so many
pawn moves and has some weaknesses in
the position black played this a five
move for example let's start on the left
hand side of the board played this f5
move which weakens the b5 square the b6
square he has played this triangle
formation in the center which obviously
we can see five square and also e6 is
also is a weakness in the long run and
with the f porn moved the king is also
somewhat more insecure if you compare
that to white why does completely
compact yes got no weakness whatsoever
you can also argue that the black hair
space that's true but wider whether
within his position has absolutely no
weakness
he's got a very clean King position no
weakness down and he has got no square
weaknesses and obviously black has some
compensation for those weaknesses in
terms of space and and good pieces but
in the long run it might happen that the
position opens up and you indeed get
problems on your weaknesses this is very
often um a difference between the
computer eval and the human evaluation
the computer just sees technical ways to
defend all the weaknesses but for a
human player it can can be tricky to do
so and this is also why I am if you
watched watch the press conference thats
villa was always a bit skeptical about
his chances here I always thought that
ok i might be a right but i need to be a
need to be a very alert and this is i
think pretty true for a human player
this position can turn a bit awkward
let's see what happened not a seven and
a form yeah bishop t6 know if you're on
a good day you'll get an e5 but not at
the moment because d5 is hanging yet be
three shows what why it's a long-term
idea is he wants to play 8c form and the
tech on d5 and we see that in a couple
of moves i can put this on the board
rather quickly that's not make it to our
video on that then white has prepared to
this advanced and he actually is able to
play that let's see pollutants later we
see that white gets this in and now we
see some some of the things i was
talking about if those pawns actually
get exchanged then white has some ways
to attack the six bond now this is the
type of position where um yeah the
typical a joke about the dutch defense
comes into play very often i'm not sure
how who this quote belongs to it
very often it is said that in the Dutch
defense you very often wish you could
play a 52 f 7 and this is yeah maybe one
of those cases where the position if
black could play a five to have seven
bag like that then he's perfectly all
right well yeah it's he still has some
some some tricks too yeah some some
tricky spots to maneuver through yeah
like took it of course and queen I know
Brooksie oh I'm sorry I thought you
played Queenie to I I screwed up screwed
up on my notes the Sun moves it's not
not played rooks you want yeah of course
needed to be technically supported to
the Seaforth not black can not take
because of the hanging knight on c6 yeah
and white will get the porn back of
course yes we'll have played be five to
get rid of one of those weaknesses and
what I just described a few moves
earlier it's starting to materialize
this Bishop is strong on the long
diagonal yeah some somewhere in the king
is weakened andy sixx this week the
whole structure it slightly more
favorable for wide and we see in the
next couple of move which i think are
pretty much best play I don't really
think you can improve very much on these
moves 95 Queen to see to yeah p34 saying
Bishop to d6 yeah probably want to fight
against the night only five which went
to c6 nice villa play tonight to be six
yeah yeah this position is the critical
one in the game and as mentioned my
general assessments would be that white
is slightly better and this was also on
the general statement in the
press conference by both players they
agreed that white is slightly better
black should hold probably the type of
position where which you probably will
never win against the computer because
of Defense the weaknesses that you have
like six g6 all this slide weaknesses
also fi is a bit more week than b3 they
can probably be offended by a machine
but in a practical game it's it's tricky
yeah for example if white now would have
played night to deform which seems to be
the best move then probably queen d 7 s
going to be played and Roxy 6 yeah and
this is not very very pleasant to play
for black they both agreed that it would
have been somewhat tedious defense but
yeah like black has has chances and and
ideas still let's say here might be five
at first it looks very strong attacking
in the mission blank has a good defense
with rook c8 yeah just a possible
variation that can lead to some some
funny complications yeah what would have
been slightly better here after 94 okay
here chrome Nick we had 15 minutes left
and they were both the broth on equal
time a chronic after short thought play
droop to d4 and yeah now it's the time
again for the small exercise look at
this from the black point of view what
would you play as black here I give you
a couple of seconds and you have good
chances to find it in a couple of
seconds if you are technically alert
yeah if you cannot believe that Kramnik
actually allowed that you're in a good
company I know that I was very very much
shocked myself because Villa now can
simply take on h2 chances what he did
King takes Queen tags everyone why does
just blundered porn and in exchange very
very very uncharacteristic of chrome
legs normal play let's say but not too
uncharacteristic of his play in this
tournament he had played quite a number
of blunders already a man real blunders
not like inaccuracies and this is really
am it's just committing far too many big
mistakes to to be a contender for the
for the win in this indiscernible so
yeah hey John simply blundered this
material and yeah else wiggler took it
and now it's a question of precise play
to to convert Crowley played green c3i
well I'd I need to I need to show you
one thing this is important actually
Kramnik said in the press conference
that he actually believed when he play
group deform that he was winning and
there is this is actually a quite true
if black cannot take on age to on black
would be in quite some trouble I I first
I couldn't really believe that but I had
had a look at this also with the who the
engine support yeah black really has no
other good movie I mean it's not really
important because you can't take on edge
too but chrome Nick was right if if
black must play something else here or
somehow this capture wouldn't be allowed
then why does in very good shape let's
say black you need to move the bishop
probably we go back and we'll s probably
look a one to attack a five or Luke see
one why this is much better but ok it's
pointless you can just take edits oh
yeah and yeah white can only try to hope
for a miracle really you played Quincy
three looking
obviously towards the only hope the g7
square delivering delivering a mate yeah
Knight a5 was also possible taking it
which it first them it's not even so
terribly on yet so terribly badly
assessed by the computer but it's
probably just the loss like rook c8 yeah
this is a very very annoying now you
must play knight c6 is the only player
will move if you move the Queen there is
even coming to be one intending Roxy to
and black is on the attack and yeah 96
is a move here you don't want to play
getting into it kind of a self pin and
it is it is almost a certain win for
black let's say plays a good
prophylactic move getting out of the
checks and then you will return with the
Queen at some point it's really just an
exchange white what can try to 222 yeah
play for tricks but it shouldn't be
really successful now this is what you
played and I think this is actually
better from practical point of us now
black only has one clear winning move on
which yeah was found by spill a
playgroup to f6 and then it's not
terribly difficult but at least that
gives black chances to go wrong if you
don't play that move if you play
something else I mean besides simple
blunders yeah allowing on g7 um black
has ways to go wrong if you for instance
play a conservative looking for a group
of seven after 95 what actually is is in
it has enough play to draw this rook
simply has no good good place now if you
now go here for example the screen c6
suddenly with a double attack well
that's not not great really blacklegs
coordination but okay well look f6 it is
lamb and was
played hookie of 695 yeah I TM the
simplest is to take on afternoon this is
what's will edit just taking it but wyd
was Ross loss in any case it's a really
just hoping for a miracle look at for
Queenie to enter queen deform yeah now
the final stage is happening this rook
is introduced into players law and after
Luke g3 there are multiple ways to win
there also was now look c2 which
probably when I when I was looking at
the slightest would have been my move
and it would have won also one point B
in 97 rugby to check first you think
black has blundered something back back
you have this check way to get into a
very comfortable working in front end
game on yeah look see to also winner
swidler played f4 and after that Kramnik
resigned the game it's simply just
simply no move for anymore and while
you're down material and you don't have
heavens that's really bit much yeah a
terrible game really far for chronic
right after he lost this strange game
against kayaking now is losing this with
a really one move blunder this check
this move yeah well there is it this is
a type of blunder that is um I guess
attributed to the fact that the queen is
on a somewhat unusual spot on b5 and you
you really only are focused on the left
hand side of the board probably this is
why push up h2 is even a move that you
can I'm not trying to find an apology or
anything you should definitely see it
but this is probably am a reason why
this is somewhat untypical a move
capture on h2 okay what does this mean
for the tournament standings and the
chances of the players yeah chrome neck
is now on minus one and yeah you see out
of it yeah i would say ninety nine
percent yes the only absolutely
miniscule chance would be the next round
where he has got right against island if
he would win this game just for
argument's sake then well still is only
on fifty percent then but Alan would be
back on plus 2 and well okay you can
sort of imagine a scenario where chrome
League winning another game are not
losing yeah and honor Kramnik would have
the better tie break compared to two
vishy if it would win the direct game
but chrome degree seems to be in a
terrible shape I mean this is very
untypical blundering those one movers
and yeah I really don't see him winning
this game maybe if you can get in some
some great preparation it can happen
sometimes players really walk onto this
kind of landmines that have been
prepared and then you just win the game
automatically without really a young
needing any great form so to say if you
just need to reproduce your analysis
this can always happen but it's not very
likely to to to happen brother Alan
looks really stable so I don't really
see that happening as for spiller I
actually believe that he has slight
chances now very slight then I know he's
only on fifty percent but he's got a
game still against are not in the last
round with black admittedly which is not
ideal but swindler at least can imagine
some scenario where he wins one of the
next three games on maybe drawing all of
them and then in the last round of his
training are not only by one point we
could actually overtake him by just a
win just a win not easy but it's a
d a possible at him to to imagine that
and yeah then this tie break with the
direct results come into effect end with
this wins villa would have the better
tie rack compared to two honored yeah
well off all all theory all speculation
we need to see what happens in the next
couple of rounds yeah I hope you enjoyed
the coverage for this game thanks for
watching